our next guests are a mother and
daughter duo who took their love for
beauty and style and turned it into a
family business
elementary school teacher jasmine and
her husband james and their
four-year-old daughter serenity created
a company during the pandemic called
serenity nail polish and a few months
ago they even launched their own website
so i think it's fair to say they're
really nailing it
um and they're joining us right now
please welcome jasmine james and
serenity phoenix
[Applause]
hi cutie
hello
hi
wow i really love your branding it's
very clean now jasmine how did this all
start
so
um it actually started during the
pandemic um my daughter and i we love to
get our nails polished that's our
bonding time show me your nails
it's nap time
i love it so you're in you love painting
your nails
yes we love painting our nails and my my
daughter came to me she said one day
mommy there's no more nail polish i'm
like
no that's it baby girl like
it's a pandemic like the stores are
closed and she said to me at three
serenity nail polish i'm like what does
that mean
i gotta figure it out um but the next
morning i kept thinking about it over
and over and i was like maybe we should
make our own nail polish and so we
started to do research um we started to
brainstorm and we said we need to make
this like
you know our own and it was super
important for it to be a vegan nail
polish company i think that's super
important to tell our viewers so randy
let me ask you a question why do you
love nail polish so much
because
yeah let me shine what's your favorite
color purple pink and rainbow there we
go
james are you so proud of your wife and
daughter for coming up with a company
honestly like you know there's not a day
that goes by where i just sit back and i
say wow it's definitely
like just seeing my you know my wife and
my daughter every day just waking up
just doing whatever it takes like this
is a real you know cozy or partnership
where i watch them do you know the
conversations like you know picking out
the polishes you know picking out the
videos the photo shoots the outfits so
they they really have a very
collaborative team even though she's
only four years old soon to be five but
it's definitely something that
as a husband as a father just as an
admirer i'm proud of all for them
well we love supporting small businesses
here on our show and we wanted to build
your brand so we reached out to our
friends at um the premiere kid spa it's
called sweet and sassy they have 14
locations around the country and they
want to feature your nail polish across
their stores nationwide
and sweet and sassy is the place where
kids can do all of their fun stuff like
get mayonnaise and future looks and kind
of you know express themselves and
i'm really excited because i think the
future looks really bright for your
company as well as them i think it is
such a good match
right yes thank you so much
thank you
thank you
we're also i'm going to put you on our
little book of small businesses gift
guide and we release that throughout the
year
and we're going to feature you in the
holiday edition so that everybody can
get serenity nails
think so much from the bottom of our
hearts like this really means a lot my
husband is probably thinking like hold
it together because i'm a crier
[Laughter]
but i am
we are very like truthfully thankful and
like bridge is so grateful and
this is just beyond what we can
ask of so thank you so much thank you
guys
thank you serenity good for you for
being a ceo at your age i wish you the
best of luck and we can't wait to follow
up and hear how it's all going thank you
thank you
[Music]
you